i watched uh the way of the husband on
netflix as well i have the house husband
that's it yeah yeah i mean i enjoyed it
a lot i thought it was very funny i was
i haven't had an anime maybe laugh out
loud constantly it's fine it's hilarious
it's like two hours yeah i mean it's i
thought it was going to be
like 10 episodes 24 minutes but it's
like five episodes in like 12 15 minutes
yeah i only saw three episodes i was
like i got the rest of the season to
binge i didn't know it was only five
episodes
yeah okay i kind of it kind of sucked
that it literally just
like it just ended it was like this is
the last skit it's tough bye-bye
and then it was like there was no ending
or anything it wasn't right see you next
time or anything and there was
it was just like okay skid over go the
[ __ ] home get out of here
because because each of the chapters in
the manga are really really short yeah
like maybe like five six pages like max
well i thought the pacing was fantastic
yeah i know obviously it caused a lot of
controversy with the animation yeah i
saw a lot of people claiming on twitter
ah i just couldn't decide i flip-flopped
there were some sketches where i felt
they did it really good
yeah and there was somewhere i'm like
holy [ __ ] this was so lazily done
right and it depended on the sketch well
i i think it just went down to the
classification because i think we've
briefly talked about this in trash days
after that like my opinion of it was
that
it's not so much an anime in the
traditional sense where it's basically
just a
motion comic it is it is just a moment
where she has labeled that and
advertises that yeah
but i i adapt yeah but i feel if you've
labeled it as
motion comic adaptation then i think
less people would have been interested
in it right unfortunately unfortunately
but then also you because i've set this
expectation that this is going to be a
thing that might happen
because i feel like it was that and it
being on netflix as well netflix really
picking this up which gave it like
people preconceived expectations because
to me i watched it
i thought it was funny as [ __ ] i thought
the animation worked for some of the
jokes
like it's it's up there with like i
thought it was just as funny as like
sakamoto for me if not funnier
yeah like it was so goddamn funny and it
scratched that itch that i didn't know i
was longing for
yeah i was every single episode i was
[ __ ] cackling laughing out loud
it's it's like that weird like
surrealist comedy right it's so good you
just don't know what's
what he's going to say next yeah and
every time you feel like you've figured
out how absurd he is he just does
something else yeah he's [ __ ] funny
if you haven't watched it please go and
watch it it's just about like a yakuza
member who gets married and straightens
out and has become a housewife
yeah and yeah it's just really funny but
it would have been like it would have
been a nine or a 10 for me if
again like i don't know if i don't
really like the the motion comic style
well would you do you think it would
have been funnier with say just mediocre
adaptation
like obviously mediocre animation sorry
genuinely yeah because
there was so little animation on it
anyway and there's just times i'm like i
wish they did a little bit on this just
to help sell the joke
i i feel like the lack of animation
helps sell some jokes
if anything i agree i agree some of them
just because it some of it just
looked ridiculous and that to me just
made it more funny
but imagine this anime in like ninja
style yeah but like
name another comedy anime that's on
niche joe level
there isn't but i'm just saying like if
you had the choice no if i had the
choice between
that i'd always go for [ __ ] nietzsche
animation even like conor super
animation right yeah because connoisseur
i think a lot of people underestimate
how good the character animation in
conor super is i've already sold
so much of the voice acting performance
where a lot of other comedy anime i feel
have fallen flat because
you have amazing voice acting
performance you have amazing source
material and the animation
is just like the okay okay animation
that really does
nothing to enhance the source material
i think i was just shocked at how little
there was yeah
whereas with where the house husband had
amazing voice acting obviously had
amazing source material and i feel like
because they didn't try it kind of like
suited that comedy style
perfectly right and and and i feel like
to me if you couldn't have amazing
animation i would have preferred to have
it have like just not not even like bad
animation just like a very
unique style of limited animation that
really helped sell
some of the weirder and more ridiculous
parts of the manga because it is a
ridiculous manga and i i feel like the
animation style
helped incentuate some of the ridiculous
moments to me yeah there's some moments
where i was like yeah okay this joke
works
with this animation there's others where
i'm like yeah this really needed more
to help some of this joke i don't know
that personally i feel like maybe a mix
could have
like really really propelled it did you
have you have you seen clips of the
there's a japanese live action
adaptation i have you seen this i've
seen it
it's so bad it's it's so funny
it's like it's it's tragic wait what's
that describe it to me
it's just like okay the main guy it
looks like a cosplay
it doesn't it is a cosplay yeah like it
looks like a cosplay not like an
actual actor yeah huh like the guy
isn't like built enough he's quite it is
like
formal alchemists like that and then his
friend
and then his friend in the anime who is
really young and supposed to be like the
young gang member yeah looks really
[ __ ] old
and like i mean i didn't watch it like
fully i only watched like clips of it on
youtube and i was like
oh no it's bad because i there's like a
there's a i watched the same skit
both of them compared yeah like the the
humor just wasn't
nearly as good in the live action i
don't know why i feel like they didn't
because with animation you can really
sell the absurdity and then they like
that's the point right yeah yeah but
yeah but they didn't work very well yeah
yeah